Freak bitches,
like I remember when I lived in Aspen,
they have the Esi body guard academy
and aspect that stand that I don't know,
but the guy supposedly was in a room six
by 12 room where he killed 12 Mexicans
at knife point with his bands.
So he opens up this uh,
Esi thing and it's,
you know,
it's 20 g's,
it's,
it's a summer long program and you learn
how to adjust up at the high altitude
and drive and evasive
driving and shooting.
Then they have a course on maritime,
how to defend people out on
the ocean and all that stuff.
But uh,
she aspen and all those
places like Woody Creek,
where you went to his home,
to the baddest retired soldiers in the
world and you don't know who they are.
You just think that dude over there with
the American flag is mowing the lawn.
That guy killed 80 people
want to add them because got,
just got endeavor that I know.
I'm telling you,
I'm Colorado,
is where they put them.
Why,
why they put them.
Because the mountain is to keep them
away from civilization for these people
just in case they get
Chinese music somewhere else.
Don't ever want that to happen.
Break glass in case of war.
And there was a guy that came in that
was the marine that bro Joe know anybody
comes in with stories.
I know one thing when I see it,
I believe it.
The motherfucker used to get picked up
at Aspen and put in the helicopter job
like they said,
like a helicopter with two guys jumping
out for guys around them and he would
just wave and uncle joey.
I was 19 and he would
tell me stories about,
you know,
the green berets and all these guys were
sitting around the thing cooking chili
and it was telling how
many people they killed.
Killed 18.
I killed 22.
Meanwhile he was stirring the
soup with his big over the fire.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that's the type of
stories this guy would tell me.
He had me all fucked up in their
head and I asked him once I go,
should I go to that Esi?
And he goes,
listen,
I go in there and smack
them all with my left hand,
and he goes,
first of all,
you can't teach what you need to learn
over there because four years of Charlie
and the Bush is a lot
better than 12 weeks.
Are you hanging out with some white dudes
which suits shooting people targets in
the mind?
It's not real.
It's not until there's real concert
six that is a big part of what the,
uh,
election was about talking me.
You making a say and think things
or just letting things be real.
Well,
it goes in cycles.
We go one way and we go the other way.
That's what it is.
It's just like we got tired of
people going so hard politically.
Correct.
But you see how there's progress now.
Like we were talking about school.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
you can't,
I mean that's good.
People would walk into our schools,
kids would walk up to other
kids that were kind of slow.
What are you retarded
like right to their face.
Look at him.
He was a sped.
He's retarded that exist anymore.
And I think it still exists,
it just exists less and not where your
kids go to school in comparison to where
you go to school.
I mean a bit of La unified and
you're hanging out in compton.
I bet you see some bad shit in school.
Probably.
This is probably some bad shit's
still going on in a lot of schools.
A lot of kids are getting bullied and
people understand the consequences of that
now.
Like you're scared to go to class
cause someone's going to hit you,
scared to go to class.
Someone's beat new.
But bullying was just part
of life isn't bullying.
It was just life back then.
But it was just bullying and
it did ruin people's lives.
Did.
But nobody called it out.
No adult would help you out with it.
No,
it's just the way it went.
You have to learn how
to take care of Shit.
And everyone was being
bullied by somebody else.
It was a,
it was dog eat dog.
It was.
Yup.
You know,
I don't know.
I think that you're right.
I mean the politically correct thing.
There's it swings that way and you're
left with some good stuff and everybody
adjusted and then it goes too far and
you start to go after things that don't
affect a lot of people.
Yeah,
and then people get fed up.
I will those.
The thing is those people that go
too far that go too far with all that
politically correct stuff,
they're almost always
emotionally unbalanced,
so given enough time they will reveal
themselves to be either crazy or power
hungry or like really like a big part
of that whole social justice warrior
movement is really about shaming people,
like expressing anger,
attacking people,
gaining power,
punching people that disagree with you,
like punch,
fascist punch,
punch Nazis like aggressive about it,
and that somehow know that this is a
good thing as if because there's so
delusional on so detached from real
physical violence and they had this idea
that you're just going to go out there
and push these people and take back.
No,
they're going to show up with guns.
You fuck like this is how
wars get started to escalate.
You try to control people.
You pushed too far.
You're not kind.
Instead you're shaming people,
you're creating bad
feelings and aggression,
like they've got this juvenile idea
about confrontation that it just goes out
there and it never comes back to you.
It always comes back with luck.
Yeah.
It comes back.
I mean,
as much as,
as,
as the son was to walk
into his father's shoes,
uh,
it's just not worth it,
man.
It's really nice and you're
probably not going to be as good.
That's just how,
what have you kid wanting to fight?
Like a bar,
like box?
Yeah,
boxer,
kick boxer.
I wouldn't advocate that either.
You wouldn't let them do that.
I'm pushing them to go
towards like a education.
I want them to be scientists.
Like if I had to do it over again,
I wouldn't have never played football.
I really,
yeah,
it'd be a scientist.
Not even.
You would start from the beginning,
like if you could go back to college
and knowing what you know now.
Wow.
Not even close and just because
of the damage to your body.
Well that and uh,
so it's,
it's a weird,
it's a weird thing.
So like,
you're,
you're in your prime physically as a,
as a man,
but you're,
you're in your infancy mentally,
right?
Right.
And so like I'm just now figuring out
who am and what kind of man I want to be
and you're,
you're,
while you're in your prime,
that's when you're in the public eye,
so you have to deal with all of that on
top of figure so you're figuring out who
you are,
uh,
in a fishbowl.
And it's a really weird,
really weird thing.
So I don't even want to deal like,
like any kind of
recommendation or any kind of
fame or whatever people want to call it.
Like I don't,
I don't like it,
I don't want it.
I feel like the best to me,
the best uh,
society would be a artist and a scientist.
That would be a ideal society to me.
Wow,
that's an interesting take on things.
Considering how successful
you've been playing football,
playing football,
obviously it was very financially
rewarding to you made you famous.
Sure.
I mean if just some regular dude went
on twitter and start talking about I can
take a wool farmer.
I know that he killed,
nobody will care and be like,
shut up,
stupid that anybody cares anyway,
but it's
fucking my twitter bloated.
But I said you were coming on
school
was going to kill us.
I don't know man.
Um,
it's,
it's a,
it's a weird.
I'm like,
once you get to that,
to that financial summit that everybody
strives for that American dream.
You realize that there is no there
and if you ain't happy with $10,
you're not gonna be happy with a million.
It's just not happening.
Um,
now granted there are
some things that you need,
you need monetary,
a value in the society to,
to a certain extent.
I think they did a study.
It's like after $75,000 a year,
money can't buy happiness.
So everything else out
there is kind of just,
it's just luxury.
And really if you put a perspective,
I think like 35 percent.
I mean if,
if you,
if you make $35,000 a year,
you're in the top one percent
of wealth in the world.
Yeah,
something like that.
So,
um,
it's all about perspective,
man.
And once,
once,
once I,
it took me to get to that financial
summit to understand that unfortunately,
but the weird thing about it is once you
tell people that and you're on top of
this financial summit for you to say,
I'm like,
all right,
of course.
Yeah.
Easy for you to know.
A lot of miserable millionaires.
Yeah.
I was on a,
on a concord with Mohammed Ali,
uh,
and um,
the,
uh,
and he,
had his,
uh,
Angelo Dundee is that the guy?
He had his entourage with him.
And uh,
the uh,
he was very nice man.
Very nice.
I only met him that one time and uh,
that's not true.
I was in the cotton club in 1978
cotton club black nightclub used to be.
And um,
the,
uh,
there was a black comedian and I was
trying to a red a Red Fox Fox and I'm the
only white guy in the audience.
And he said something about white people.
So I had been tuned up pretty good.
And in back in [inaudible] 78,
I thought it was pretty tough.
I stood up and I said
something back to them.
Now this went over like
a Turd in a punch bowl.
I mean all these people
that are around me,
all the color of Fox and so fox is,
hey,
you don't want to come up here.
And so I go.
And then Mohammed Ali was sitting about
six tables over and he protected me.
He said,
we've got to let this white boy alone.
I mean,
no,
we don't want a problem here.
So then I say,
well,
yeah,
you don't have to protect me.
I just was up 80 young.
Yeah.
And I tried to pay the
bill in Muhammad Ali says,
no,
your money's no good here.
The money's not a great job.
Oh No.
Yeah.
They didn't,
not forcibly but,
but they essentially.
Yeah.
Then I take care.
Get out of here with your life.
You're correct.
Correct.
But anyway,
so,
uh,
but um,
yeah,
I had a big mouth.
Listen,
Dan Pena.